la logique a été respectée en finale de
la coupe des yvelines seniors au gymnase
des lavandières de saint-germain-en-laye
ce dimanche 19 juin les joueurs de
plaisir qui évolue en prénationale ont
battu montigné obtenu une équipe de
division honneur régionale le score est
sans appel 39 à 26 début de match un peu
compliqué défensivement on n'était pas
présent
mais qu'on a un appui défendre un peu
plus fort sur l'homme on a plus joué les
montées de balle les contre attaques
est-ce que je vais pas me parler car en
début de deuxième mais à un moment on a
défendu un peu plus bas on a pu monter
les ballons
visés
physiquement la blonde images on les
voyait qu'il mettait un peu d'intensité
nous on reste sur le même tempo c'était
important pour vous était plus fort sur
le plan physique
à la surprise des gabarits ce plan aussi
sur plan foncier ou au niveau des
courses
mes joueurs étaient fatigués que les
heures de plaisir le match on savait
salle est difficile mais une très belle
chose de la part de
des collectifs saignant de montigny
pas de musique
une victoire importante pour les
plaisirs oies les jaune et noir ont raté
la montée pour la deuxième année
consécutive en terminant à la deuxième
place de prénationale derrière paris
sport club
selon le staff et les joueurs cette
coupe des yvelines récompense leur
saison encourageant comme l'année
dernière on a fini deuxième du
championnat donc pas de monter mais dans
la coulisse divine pour se réconforter
et on va retourner son appart
prochain objectif pour plaisir l'année
prochaine conserver la coupe des
yvelines et enfin accrocher la montée en
nationale 3